before we get in this juicy episode of
the shop show covering Nate Diaz Jake
Paul it went down this last Saturday
Phoenix I will see you this freaking
Friday two shows stand up live in
Phoenix Arizona August 11th this
freaking Friday and then Omaha Nebraska
one night only August 16th Kansas City
Missouri one night only August 17th in
Covina Laugh Factory with Brian Callan
and myself were together for the first
time in a hot second that's September
8th through the 9th in Covina California
then Spokane Washington September 21st
through the 23rd get your tickets see
you this Friday Phoenix
take your shot at huge wins with
DraftKings Sportsbook you could win big
with money lines props parlays and so
much more right now new customers can
score 150 dollars in bonus bets
instantly for betting just five dollars
on anything you you have the fight night
uh this Saturday with Vicente Luce and
um dos anjos you got a lot of stuff to
bet on you got MLB popping right now so
download the rafting Sportsbook app
right now use code shop show that's seh
AB show let's go shop show only on
draftking Sportsbook gambling problem
call 100 Gambler New York call 8778 Hope
and why or text Hope and why that's
467-369 in West Virginia visit
www.1800 gambler.net in partnership with
Hollywood Casino at Charlestown Races
all games regulated by the West Virginia
Lottery please play responsibly in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 888-789-777
or visit
ccpg.org on behalf of Boot Hill Casino
Resort Kansas 21 or older in most
eligible States but age varies by
jurisdiction see draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details and
state-specific responsible gambling
resources bonus bets expire seven days
after issuance eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply terms at
sportsbook.draftkings.com baseball terms
what is up there Monday August 7th it is
a glorious day here it it don't even
twist it it's hot here but nothing like
a Texas Austin hot I think they're
they're going like over 20 days over
102.
Cal and I were
walking around on Saturday in Austin
Texas
dude I sweated out my shirt I sweat out
my jeans
it's not the end of the world though
Houston that that humidity that's
different
us I can do it and there's AC so Cry Me
a River you know you're from Texas chin
I know but I remember being it's it
being super hot but it was we had AC
even like the little unit by the window
you can navigate your way through if
people even live in Vegas and Phoenix
you can navigate your way through it
speaking of Phoenix I'll be there this
Friday two shows stand up live baby
stand up live two shows on Friday that's
this Friday and Saturday I'll be I'll be
at the UFL fights with Chan browse yeah
big J shop shark guys doll smile we'll
all be there man ufl's going down be a
fun one we'll be at JT's Wings did you
go with me last time at JT's Wings never
oh Jay's like that you have to go yeah
yeah we go every time that's the best of
the best best wings you ever tried best
best thing you put in that mouth Playboy
you feel me all right Doug
yeah shout out to Austin it's a great
time did the fight command Mr Joseph
Rogan Eddie Bravo Callum was on stage so
he missed it we did the fight companion
um for Jake Paul and Nate Diaz and also
the UFC fight night
um yeah there's the boys
there's the boys we had a grand old time
man we had a dinner right before this
that uh Brian uh was able to go to
because that five and it was me Rogan
Eddie Brian and Alex Jones
wow it was an interesting interesting
dinner because you know Brian's kind of
that woke left [__] uh Vibe and then
you're dealing with
five Savages on the other side between
me out now there's
I should put it like this when it comes
to like politics and the you know
conspiracies it's like it would go Alex
Jones is over here Eddie's right behind
him
then Rogan's here and then I'm here and
then Brian's all the way over here so it
is four against one and Brian was trying
to say that
um
I was trying to say that uh Jeffrey
Epstein was um
not murdered and boy he lost that round
ten to six boy did he pick a fight he
could not win I mean they were just
dropping facts on him after fat I mean
it was it got it got ugly it got ugly I
didn't say a word I was like Jesus
Christ This is
throwing the towel calling throwing the
goddamn towel it was a great time man
next one we might do in September if
they announce Izzy versus uh Sean
Strickland which is the word it hurts a
Strickland Visa issue is that the rumors
going around yeah that's a rumor but
apparently they're
they seem like they're working through
it so it should happen hopefully yeah
because September 6 not too far away was
that four weeks away three weeks away
three
damn it yeah it's already freaking
August yeah I don't know but I'm sure
Izzy and Strickland are trading they're
just like hey let's UFC's probably like
let's figure out the Visa issues but
yeah
um yeah hopefully they announce that
freaking soon that's a great fight the
only shame on that is because it wasn't
out sooner we're not getting like the
build up because Strickland goes hard in
the paint a little too hard sometimes
depends your cup of tea yeah
uh speaking this week however coach
nixic revealed the team was ready to
head down under as soon as it was signed
off by local authorities all signs are
pointing in a good direction but right
now all he's worked on is getting his
Visa in order and hopefully in the gym
uh the signs look like it's a yes it's
all pointed in a good direction but
hasn't been official yet so we're kind
of a holding patch just that Visa part
yeah
they get a UFC thing you get done
because Australia that's a huge fight is
he done there's no other opponent they
need Izzy to headline that fight I
guarantee it gets done come on hey
Australia be cool it's not like Sean
Strickland's just some random dude
either you know you could also fly in
private and just avoid all that there's
ways around that
that'll be dope they did private I mean
yeah because I don't know if he has like
a felony or something it's tough yeah
there's ways around that
there's ways around that but uh yeah
let's get right into it man you had
uh UFC Fight Night
Tatiana swarza uh
is your MVP of the night she's coming on
a long layoff fighting you know a
freaking monster and Jessica and Josh
and just bullied that girl just bullying
Tatiana is just such a a freak when it
comes to women's throw weight division
she used to fight at 125 at 115 she
looks freaking great and she just
dominated Jessica and Josh which is no
Punch drink number five uh Suarez is
number 10 which you know she should be I
I know she had to get a fight and get a
win over a top five opponent but she'd
be three or two you know her skill level
but still undefeated she's already beat
the the champion Alyssa Grosso she's had
some other big wins I just she's the the
khabib of the the Women's Division I
just don't see anybody being there you
know and and your girl uh Zhang Wei Lake
and come get it covina's finest Tatiana
Suarez are getting it done man yeah I
think everybody knew that was gonna
happen though Justin Jacoby had a great
knockout
do your Lopes had a fantastic submission
arm bar out of the triangle
um and so that leaves just uh Billy
quarantino got it done definitely gave
him the decision 2928 uh takedowns if
you think I was controversial then you
don't know the scoring system
um when it comes to Corey sandhagen
who's my boy he heard his uh he said he
tore his tricep in the first round which
is a it was a big deal I didn't know
that you know obviously we don't hear
anything commentating I don't know if
they announced it on the broadcast we
don't hear any of it when we're doing
fight commands so not knowing that I was
like oh he's playing it too safe
now I get why he played it safe
I do and I don't because
and they said Dana walked out during the
fourth round he's like I'm out of here
man so it just doesn't do Corey any good
um as far as getting hit you know
getting a title shot when you when you
play it safe like that but now you see a
torn tricep you're out for a hot second
and I think it was like official too
because his uh you know the suspect the
suspensions they give you afterwards
he's apparently suspended for a long
time until he gets that check yeah
checked out yeah most times you need
surgery on that that's a bad one yeah
you know there's been football players
that retire from that
uh says data so this is spinning at
spinning back fist Dana White walked out
during the fourth round
Dan just walked out of the Arena he's
getting filled with booze and he didn't
show up to the post office Corey yeah it
you know it's just not gonna do you any
favors when you play it safe you know
Dana he says that for Corey I expected
more I expected to finish it you can't
beat the Gap too much you're talking
about you're torn tricep it's a big big
deal man but
yeah he played it safe and and now
there's not a chance he's next in line
for a title shot unless there's like
major injuries probably two guys and he
get injured before they looked his
Direction
um
I would be willing to bet the UFC's like
all right you're gonna fight new Martin
another Madoff next like we're not we're
not entertaining anything else but that
after a performance like that because
they know he can't take Umar down like
this and be forced to strike with him so
that's what they're gonna do so he said
I love the crowd I want to put on a good
show of course to me that's a beautiful
martial arts none of that people want to
see blood that's how it is I've given
them plenty of blood in the past this is
the way I have to win tonight
uh it's kind of funny said the post
right press conference the fans were
booing but the reason almost that it was
the way it was because I really wanted
to be there for them
huh
um yeah he's just he's just not
he'd been better just if
he'd been better if he injured himself
like the week before and didn't take the
fight and then the hype would still be
on because now you know once you have
that kind of black guy no pun intended
Dana White's not gonna do any favors
Karen you fight two more next well
depends how long he's out with the the
tricep injury that's a that's a rough
one really rough injury then algeman and
Henry sigota also tweeted about him uh
don't anyone ever tell me or marab that
we're boring and don't do anything with
takedowns audacity thank you Corey
saying after that done of a performance
it's me verse marab for the next shot at
the bandweight strap he's right
he's right
he had to the the credit you'd give to
Corey is
two-week replacement you're fighting a
straight up Grappler in uh Umar and then
he goes completely 360 and then you're
fighting a guy with zero grappling just
heavy hands
you gotta put that guy away though man
you just do at this level or at least if
you got to go for a broke like he did
towards the end of the fifth round
he kept trying to pull that off like
dude where was that energy the second
third fourth
it's just a bummer you know and the the
physical fan base like oh he's garbage
like man you know like dope performances
Corey's had so he always gives your last
fight they're not gonna do many favors
he's gonna pay for this one just nature
of the business and if you're Dana and
you're in the business of entertainment
which it is yeah especially as the main
event especially as the main event and
you're competing when I I shouldn't say
competing but same night as Nate Diaz
Jake Paul you know you want to be the
talk to the town and that did not leave
a good taste in your mouth but quite
nonetheless got the win but to punish
him quote unquote punished by giving
Umar guarantee it again Umar is probably
gonna fight before then because Corey's
uh torn tricep is not something you just
rehab and comes back you usually have to
have surgery on that so I'd assume Umar
fights and then as soon as Corey's ready
they're going to give him Umar that's
how it goes which would be better Umar
be ranked higher so it's a better better
look for Corey for her to be to me if it
was a boring one but I don't think that
can be a boring fight unless Umar is
just you know humping them the entire
fight but that's tough to do with Corey
Santa Hagen let's take a little break
from chatting about the Real Housewives
of the fight game if you could trade a
benchwarmer for a goat that means
greatest of all time you do it right get
your business a game-changing pickup by
choosing the Commerce platform with the
internet's best converting check out
that Shopify Shopify is the Commerce
platform revolutionizing millions of
businesses worldwide whether you're a
garage entrepreneur or IPO ready Shopify
is the only tool you need to start and
run and grow your business without the
struggle Shopify puts you in control of
every sales channel so whether you're
selling satin sheets from shopify's
in-person POS system we're offering
organic olive oil on shopify's
all-in-one e-commerce platform we got
you covered all right Sports cool
selling signed sneakers offering
official outfielders outfits we got you
all covered fight more in shorts they
got it all using Shopify once you've
reached your in Shopify has the
internet's best converting checkout to
help you turn them from browsing to
buyers we got you covered man Shopify
Powers 10 of all e-commerce in the US
and Shopify is truly a global Force
powering all birds rothies Brooklyn and
millions of other entrepreneurs of every
size across over 170 countries all right
this is possibility powered by Shopify
sign up for a one dollar per month trial
period at shopify.com lowercase shop
again that's all lowercase go to
shopify.com shop lowercase to take your
business to the next level today today
today
shopify.com lowercase shop
this episode of the shop show is brought
to you by my one and only one of my
favorite products on the freaking planet
we're talking about that juicy juicy
stuff from my friend that happy hippo
that's Happy hippo.com they got the K
dips this is freaking fantastic because
you know I like to dip and I can do it
with happy hippo this is Wintergreen
they get the Razzle Dazzle fruity flavor
they got powders they got gummies they
got the highly concentrated shots they
got energy shots leaves you with a nice
warm balance good mood feeling get your
brain firing get your body right for
whatever task you have that day with
this podcasting stand up going to the
gym being a dad Whatever It Is My
Friends that happy hippo got the best in
the biz that's Happy hippo.com promo
code is thick23 that's thick with three
C's 23 you save 20 for Life by using
thick 23 code that's the promo code
happyhippo.com for the best products on
the planet talking about happy hippo
promo codes thick23 you're welcome let's
get back to the program uh but the talk
to the town was not the UFC Fight Night
in Nashville
it was Jake Paul and Nate Diaz you guys
watched it of course
yeah did you guys leave me streaming or
what are we talking about here
you purchased I bought it purchased okay
you guys are good Fellas these are good
people
um
yeah this fight was I was surprised you
know I
this fight was predicated on what
version of Nate Diaz we were gonna get
um
you know we know Jake Paul's young but
he only has what's
six fights at the time he was what five
and one
right or does he have eight fights
either how many fights do you have
um so he has eight fights tall so seven
fights go into this so you're talking
about a kid who's young but specializes
in just boxing which is his Advantage
because the boxing match he only has
seven fights and he's fighting a guy
Nate Diaz who has zero boxing fights but
has boxing experience getting ready for
MMA camps
um he's helped out Delights of Andre
Ward and stuff like that so he knows his
way around the boxing ring
so it was this young up-and-comer
YouTuber influencer boxer versus you
know a legend uh in MMA Nate Diaz but an
older Nate Diaz a guy who has some miles
on him is he taking the fight serious I
did not personally bet on this I had a
lot of people ask me and I said I just
it's tough to bet against Jake on this
we don't know what version of Nate we're
gonna get and I don't like betting on
that but if it's uh an ideas who's all
in that
Not a Bad Bet and whatever was plus 375
plus 400 not a bad
put 100 bucks you know win 400 there if
it's plus 400 so it's not a terrible
idea to take that chance only 100 bucks
and if you can win 400 it's not a bad
bet so what did we get and that's why a
lot of predictions yeah not too many
people predicted uh I think a decision
it was either you know Nate finishes
them off later in the rounds or Jake
gets them out there early and I thought
it was all predicate on no matter what
version of Nate we get if Nate can
weather those first three rounds and
because they're much younger more
explosive only focus on boxing Jake Paul
cannot get him out of the first three
rounds it's going to be more tailored
towards Nate Diaz that was not the case
here because if you go to the copy
strike numbers Jake Paul not only
matched the output of Nate Diaz which
Nate Diaz is known for that but not only
the match but he beat him in the overall
volume which is insane for a kid with
only eight fights insane but I I listen
I really think the takeaway here is you
know a lot of people like oh that fight
was trash or here we go
so do they have the total punches keep
going down they have like the total is
not round by round here we go so
um Power punches
so power punches uh thrown 140 for Jake
135 for Nate total Jabs 34 for Jake only
eight
and that's to the body and I only ate uh
by uh Nate total punches of the body uh
174.
oh no this is way off it's backwards
power punches
Jake threw uh 289
and DS through 347.
and then when you go to Total Jabs uh
Jake threw 202 which is insane and uh
Nate through 45.
total total punches uh Nate through 392
Jesus Christ Jake through 100 more
punches through 491. sort of out
Pace uh innate Diaz is just insane would
not have predicted that definitely
didn't predict that shows you how
serious Jake took this fight
but I do think the overall takeaway
should be this there's a lot of people
going oh that was trash this was a good
fight
if you're basing off of last week's
phenomenal fight of pound number one
versus pound for per pound for pound
number two or number three in uh Spence
versus Crawford Crawford being the
number one pound for pound guy and
Spence being number three I think they
have inua as number two or one just
depends but either way you have a top
three pound-for-pound boxers on the
planet competing at the highest level in
actual boxing all they do is focus on
boxing
so I I think the one of the reasons why
both these gentlemen take a lot of flack
for this is you're assuming it's like
that
but what everybody is forgetting is just
because Nate is a quote-unquote
well-known boxer in the UFC does not
make you a great overall boxer in the
sport of boxing just because Anderson
Silva is one of the greatest strikes of
all time in the UFC does it doesn't mean
it actually correlates to actual boxing
so even though Anderson is known for
being a good Striker for one of the best
of all time being a good boxer Nate Diaz
known for really his box and more so for
jiu jitsu and UFC but his boxing ain't
too shabby his output he's knocked out
some of the best guys to ever do it in
UFC that doesn't mean it's going to
correlate to the actual sport of boxing
there's such a big difference the
distance you have to worry about more
things in in MMA there's a ton of
variables the the footwork so I think
people are expecting a version of Nate
Diaz because we label them as this boxer
but he's good for MMA boxing it's a big
big difference and you saw that
difference because Jake Paul doesn't
have that MMA background all he does is
focus on boxing all he's competing is
against boxers day in and day out uh in
that ring in Puerto Rico is it Puerto
Rico yeah it's Puerto Rico right
so that so he's gonna look Jake Paul
looked more like a boxer than Nate Diaz
did on Saturday night and that's because
that's all he does Nate does it but he
also has to worry about a lot of other
things so you saw
some of his technique with his feet are
leaving the ground uh which can get away
with that in the UFC
um the way he would he would kind of
Rush In And in in his distance and just
kind of off balance in this weird so it
looks sloppy but in MMA that works
because when you when you get so close
and you can use the grappling you can
use over unders you can wear the guy out
Nate was doing a lot of that that's his
default mode that's what Nate Diaz does
well he wears you out applies pressure
uses volume and melts guys in boxing
doesn't really work like that there's a
there's a there's a different dance you
know there's different frequency so I I
think some of the hate goes oh that was
terrible boxing yes as far as it goes
when it if you're referring to the likes
of a spence versus Crawford they're two
completely different things
you you gotta you gotta look at this as
one lane in Combat Sports in boxing in
another Lane you can't look at a kid
with seven fights and a guy with zero
boxing fights and go man that's bad
boxing compared to Spencer Crawford it's
two completely different products
I didn't assume that Jake or Nate were
going to look like Crawford or Spence if
you did you're [__] it's not not even
remotely close so
with that being said you know when I go
that was impressive win by Jake it's an
impressive win over a MMA fighter not
another Boxer and Jake this is exactly
what Jake should be doing this is where
the money is at this is where the fan
base is at an ads fan base is massive
massive and so the knock on Jake is yeah
but when he fought a real boxer he lost
yeah because he only has seven fights
keep fighting the biggest names possible
that you know fancy themselves boxers
from the UFC world and keep beating them
up and getting the the attention getting
all the money in the world that's the
move
I don't think Jake and Jake knows this
he fought one legit boxer when I say
legit boxer even that's being friendly
you're talking about a guy that came off
you know uh that love Island show and we
give him credit because his brothers the
greatest heavywin of all time in Tyson
Fury
but is Tommy Fury a legit boxer well
he's fighting KSI
in an exhibition match
that's your real boxer now compared to
the guys that Jake's fought again all
time me fury focus on is boxing so he's
gonna be look more of the part that you
guys want in in a boxer
he did not beat that guy that fight was
terrible that was not a good fight
who cares if I'm Jake I ignore the noise
man keep fighting these guys with these
huge names everyone thinks you're gonna
lose
because remember the narrative for the
longest time was this is fixed this is
fake Nate all that shit's bull all
that's [__] this is all fake these
guys are taking a fall Ben aspirin took
a fall Woodley took a fall Anson took a
fall which is insane
if you if you think of any of that you
know it's such a disgrace you're doing a
disservice to Ben askren you know who's
a Hall of Famer Woodley who's all Hall
of Famer amson Silva who's the first
bout Hall of Famer Legend You're
assuming those guys are going to
compromise their careers and their fight
Egos and take a fall for money you're
out of your [__] mind dude that was
the narrative right so when they fight
Nate well you're gonna say Nate's gonna
take a fall for money never
he's the gangster remember so then he
goes in there
and Nate that fight wasn't that close in
any facet
there was never any time you're worried
about Jake maybe the laid around you're
like yeah man Jake seems to be slowing
down a little bit but Nate's power was
never there you'll never worry about
Jake getting knocked out in any capacity
in that fight when Jake knocked him down
in the fifth and almost knocked him out
of the ring like Jesus Christ the first
round he thought he was gonna get him
out of there the fifth round even though
he knocked him down I thought it showed
composure I thought it showed a young
fighter learning from his mistakes not
trying to capitalize and get him out of
there which most young Fighters trust me
I know I tried to do it myself would
rush in there make mistakes and that's
where you lose fights I thought that was
a learning uh time for Jake and he
passed that test so this fight wasn't
that close it wasn't that close again
nor should it be all Jake does he's
younger all he focus on is boxing Nate
does not Nate's at the Twilight of his
career
he says a lot of miles on him even if he
decided to focus on boxing for the next
year he's probably still not gonna look
like Jake because he has all the muscle
memory of a grappling he's a Jitsu
specialist he has a lot of miles on him
something tough to break those
tendencies that he's developed through
fighting the UFC for how long coming off
The Ultimate Fighter is a winner in this
storied career that he's had
so this went down exactly how we thought
I thought Jake would have finished him
but I think it shows maturity him not
rushing in there and and looking for you
know the kill I I think that's a sign of
maturity so I I thought Jake looked
great I did think it was impressive
but again you guys go and that's not
impressive you know he he could have got
him out of there Nate looked like [__]
no Nate look like a guy who fought in
the UFC the last 15 [__] years and
tried to fight in a professional boxing
match that's what he looked like
it's different Nate has five he has 15
minutes you know three five minute
rounds that's a different pace there's
different pacing different kind of you
have more ways to film out you can get
away certain certain Antics stuff like
that and when Nate started to do the
antique stuff you know the the Nate Diaz
thing you know obviously his brother's
Infamous for laying down being high when
he fought Anderson Silva got the three
year suspense or whatever Nate does
things where he flips guys off and all
that stuff
I think Nate
realized he's not going to win this
fight he can't knock him out Jake's
better than he thought Jake is you know
run away on the scorecards with us he's
already knocked me down so that's a 10-8
round now let's do the Nate Diaz thing
that his fan base likes turn my back
tone talk to the guy make fun of him put
him in a get with team and so the Nate
Diaz fan base goes oh dude if this was a
street fight he would have beat him okay
and again I know you guys love that
stuff and it's just you know but that
that's a win for Nate I'm going all
right I'm not winning this thing but I
still got to win with my fan base check
this out guilty
check that [__] this guy I thought you
ain't [__] I thought the exact same
thing too like and plus he was super
tired so he's just trying to you know
take some time to do that stuff but I
mean in a real street fight you do pick
Nate though right if it was an actual
street fight yeah of course that's I
would also pick him in a basketball game
who cares that's not what that that's
not what this is I mean I just want to
make sure because you said if he was if
it was a street fight then yeah but
that's what what are we talking about
here
but that's he beat him in the sport of
boxing and which Nate admitted to people
even said like do you think he won he's
like nah who would I mean that's insane
no of course he definitely didn't win
that fight but again this you know even
he got destroyed by Lynn Edwards for
four rounds and you know four minutes
and he lands one good punch oh dude if
this was in the street
Nate wins that was the narrative in this
one the guillotine all dude if this is
real this was in the streets okay
it's not what this is just that it's
okay you know
so good for Nate and it carries on and I
don't think Nate suffered any
to his image to his fan base I think it
was smart and also you know the MMA fan
base is so fickle when it's like
we're on this guy's nuts we're on his
nuts he loses one always the worst
fighter of all time
he wins one he's lost three wins one a
crazy knock at least the best of all
time it's like politics it's these we
live in these Extremes in MMA these
major extremes and then whoever you
listen to as far as journalists goes or
podcasters or guys like me in the
entertainment fight space whoever you
listen to on Monday mornings or during
the week after a big fight
we live in extremes because when you
make a crazy statement when you make an
extreme statement oh Nate should retire
Jake's Jake's an idiot he looked
terrible those get views
those guys don't believe that
whoever you're listening to this week on
this fight and they someone does
something crazy like oh I bet Nick Diaz
would knock out Jake Paul I I Nate Diaz
should retire Nate Diaz is done that's
how you get clicked that's the business
of YouTube That's the business podcast
and that those extreme takes which
nobody really believes just like
politics there's always the extreme left
there's an extreme right most of us are
in the middle but you're not going to
get attention if you stay in the middle
so we live in these extremes and the
sport lives in these extremes because
that's what gets headlines saying I
actually thought it was a good product
oh [__]
no no be mean to him about it and also
everyone wants to fight for you know
these Fighters put their lives in you
know their health on the line they need
something to fall back on after fighting
Dana should pay them more fighter pay
it's a shame CT all this stuff and the
guy a guy like Jake Paul comes and
allows a guy like Nate Diaz to fight him
and make tens of millions of dollars and
he has hate on Jake Paul
or a Woodley who name another fight
Woodley could have got where you've got
that notoriety that amount of pay you
guys should be happy that Jake is here
man given these no matter how you feel
about him from his Disney days YouTube
days whatever his background is the
point is he's given UFC fighters that
you've watched for years take all this
trauma and not get paid like the way
they should and they're finally getting
their due and it's not it's not a
terrible gig for them and you guys are
hating on it
nobody else is doing this Dana ain't
doing this
none of these other leads you guys like
to watch are doing this all these
complaints about fighter pay and fire
equality and all this [__] and then this
kid comes along built this insane Empire
and he gives these Fighters that you
love the biggest paydays they've ever
gotten their lives and you guys hate on
it you guys hate it all this is [__]
man now this is fake these are set up
hold on but when Woodley was fighting
you guys were all upset that he wasn't
getting equal pay when Nate Diaz was
fighting and you guys were all upset
about this or that and the the man and
Dana and the UFC as in general and the
Machine they're [__] them over and he
[__] the man that's why we like Nate
and then he finally gets his biggest
payday he's saying [__] this guy
well which one is it
you guys should be selling celebrating
Jake he's giving these guys the biggest
platform they've ever had the easiest
night in the office for them because
it's just boxing there again concussed
they're not getting their arms broken
it's even this huge platform and you
guys hate on it
this guy's giving them opportunities
nobody else is giving give them the
biggest payday ever given finally their
eat what they're worth and you guys hate
on it I don't understand it
now if you want to hear that compared to
Spence and Crawford or Floyd or insert
huge name Tyson Fury you're looking at
it all wrong
you guys should be happy that Jake's
built this Empire and he's given your
favorite fires an opportunity to make
more money than they've ever made
and they they're keeping them relevant
they're keeping the fan base they're
giving us something to talk about should
be thankful shouldn't hate on it but
again if you're viewing it like it was
Tyson Furious Deontay Wilder or usick
Tyson Fury usik you're just you're you
got you're all your wires are crossed
man you're just off on this that's not
this this is something completely
different and that's okay because those
Fighters for the longest didn't get they
were devalued didn't get paid got
concussed lost fights got cut from the
UFC then finally you're getting guys
that are leaving the UFC and getting
more money than they've ever gotten
their lives that's what this is
celebrate this because I don't know how
long this can be around
I don't I don't know if there's a
long-term thing I don't know how long
Jake wants to do this I don't know how
many big names are going to be left
after you know the the Nate fight the
Conor fights there
after that it gets a little dicey
you know it gets a little dicey and does
Jake just want to keep doing this we
don't know but while it's here take
advantage of it don't [__] on it
celebrate it buy the pay-per-views
is it the same product you're getting
when it comes to Tyson fear and usick no
it's completely different but Jake Paul
is taking care of the MMA royalty that
you guys all know and love that you
complain about for years about equality
and fighter pay he's given them their
worth
that's what should be celebrated I don't
give a [__] what the product is I don't
care I'm not looking at to be these two
Elite level boxers that's not what this
is you can find that over here go watch
it did you buy the expense Crawford
fight you didn't shut the [__] up
are you gonna buy U6 next fight you're
not shut the [__] up
celebrate this he's getting these guys
paid that should be your angle he's
finally getting paying people what
they're worth what he's doing for uh
Amanda Serrano's insane dude insane
nobody else is doing that how about
Jeremy Stevens you guys like Jeremy
Stevens fights he had a big platform man
celebrate that
you guys want to complain about fight or
pay and when any Fighters go on to do
anything else outside the UFC you hate
on it
keep the same energy
you should be celebrating Fighters that
go on outside the UFC and get bigger get
more famous and make more money
across the board whatever it is yeah
there's no reason it doesn't make sense
to me hate on is strong everyone wants
to hate on Jake Paul
but he's giving he's got an opportunity
to platform to make more money than
they've ever made in their entire career
the entire careers in the UFC oh it's a
terrible product by the way I bought
that product and I didn't buy the UFC
because I you know I subscribed to ESPN
but so the UFC's a free fight I had way
more fun watching just the main event of
Jake Paul versus different card it's
something different of uh fcm yeah it
was a fun fight all over around I
enjoyed it yeah I enjoyed it I wasn't
looking at like oh man technically it
was a fun fight to watch yeah great I
was way more hyped for that could have
been uh because the smelling salts I was
way more I wanted to ask you about that
it's way more awake and hype for Jake
Paul and Nate Diaz way more is all I was
thinking about the entire weekend I was
way more focused on that than I was
Corey Sandhill and Rob font now is Corey
sanding raphon a more competitive fight
a more technical fight yes this is
different you can't view them the same
that's all I'm saying yeah and I had
more fun even though I I obviously love
San Hagen and font but I loved I really
enjoyed watching the Paul I'd watch it
all day yeah but so the small the salts
I saw you doing the taking it I think
Juju mufus I don't know he sent me a
bunch I love it but I mean so does it
affect because remember we hit we did
this the one chip challenge where it
affects you like crazy and it's hardcore
no this is it it hit you like a [__]
ton of bricks and then it's just you're
awake and like my sinuses were cleared I
could breathe he sent some to the crib
because I was like oh I want more I did
two or three times that road and he's
like you shouldn't do it too many times
like well shut your mouth I loved it
that'd be awesome that's awesome I loved
it it's so intense it burnt like I have
no idea it's not like a Wasabi like yeah
when that it's an intense Wasabi it just
like boom yeah it's like that it goes
away quick I like that that it goes away
quick I was so bored during the no shade
on Corey Sandy I was so bored during
that fight and I was you know I didn't
sleep much and then we were drinking I
was tired I'm like give me some of that
smell and salt to wake me up for this
Jake Paul fight and I was crunk dude
and it doesn't affect you for the rest
of the day it's a quick hit like 10
seconds dude let's do it here and then
you're awake yeah I've never breathed
better in my life that's even I was like
focused I loved it
loved it all right you got to bring it
in yeah absolutely loved it I think the
big before we do current events and I
think the question is what's next for
Jake Paul
that is a good question what is next
what do you think what would you do so
this other thing a lot of people aren't
given credit to is what Jake Paul Jake
Paul's team that guy with the MVP
Productions the MVP
whatever it is the the the the journey
that they're taking Jake on should
they're gonna write books about
because you look at the the level of
guys that he's fighting in his short
boxing career the amount of eyeballs
that he's bringing and just these smart
moves like could he fight uh uh
up-and-coming professional boxer who's
4-0 or 10-0 whatever sure no one's going
to pay attention I know you guys want to
see that that makes no money Jake's fans
might tune in but they're not really
boxing fans they're just Jake Paul fans
it's the the level of difficulties way
higher he only has seven fights that
doesn't make a lot of sense for them to
calculate and get a Nate Diaz and get a
Woodly twice and get an Anderson Silva
and these are favorable matchups and
these bring in the this curiosity not
only from the MMA side which is huge and
we're talking about and Dana was talking
about it not anymore but was really big
time talking about Jake Paul and just
the level of of notoriety they're
bringing it should and don't get me
wrong Jake Paul has a lot of to do with
it but the team around him is something
we've never seen man that's there needs
to be credit there like the moves that
they're making to up the ante on this
stuff and get people intrigued by it is
dude they'll write books about this it's
insane it's very calculated very smart
it's hard to pull off too like that's
why I said during the companion when
they zoomed out and you see that packed
Arena and this high level production you
got [__] Sean Porter speaking you got
Hardy there you got Ariel you got like
these real-time guys in the space
I just said look what Jake's built this
is insane dude this dude was on the
Disney Channel decided to start boxing
and in seven fights look at what he's
built yeah
I'm not saying he's gonna beat Canelo
I'm not saying he's even go that
direction nor should he
all I'm saying is where he's at look
what he's doing
despite how you feel about him despite
all that whatever with Logan Paul Jake
Paul look what these brothers pulled off
sold out arena in Dallas one of the
biggest papers of the Year got the likes
of a Nate Diaz who hated on this type of
fighting for years got him to a main
event
comes into the arena in a [__] tank
oh and his brother competed in WWE was a
massive event got a private plane and
made the fight his brother compete in
the WWE these are two kids who started
Ohio with a [__] cell phone
and they're the biggest names in
entertainment
well however you feel about him whatever
the the suicide jungle Forest in Japan
that stuff the Jake Paul stuff he did
this he had guns and I'm not saying any
of that I don't condone any of that all
I'm saying is look what two kids from
Ohio did with a cell phone on YouTube
though he's the main event in a sold out
Dallas Arena it was the Talk of the Town
dude and his brother is competing in the
WWE at the highest level this is insane
insane dude yeah
I actually recorded a clip that Jay or
not uh J Jake Paul did on YouTube
somewhere he said something about like
you know him and his brother said
something like if you find something
that you're good at just just go at it
just keep going forward this is when
they were young super young I have so
much respect for Jake Paul especially
because he didn't just do this he was he
actually trained he actually became a
good he's actually a good really good
boxer I can see this is a really good
especially with the time time seven
fights yes yeah he's an entire world
watching too yeah and you can see when
he's in the press conferences with Nate
Diaz he he puts on a little bit of a
show but then when Nate like leaves he's
like he kind of breaks character a
little bit he's like what's he doing
this and that did you watch his Netflix
stock I haven't watched enough you watch
it oh Casey told me to watch it I
checked it out the other day I'm sure
it's amazing right it's got It's dope
because you see that it's all calculated
you see that he's like super smart at
this very smart and it's all a troll job
you see that he's like yeah yeah you get
it yeah you're like oh my God he's he's
pulled it out the ultimate troll job
we're all tuning everyone hates him he
doesn't care you know that him and his
brother they've won man
I just how this is an inspiration to
everybody trying to do something taking
a risk I I will I don't understand so
much inspiration do you know the amount
of [__] huevos YouTube Brothers have
if when you're eight years old hey
you're gonna do this and this on YouTube
and then you're gonna be the face of
boxing and Logan's like what about me uh
yeah you're also gonna be pretty big in
boxing you're gonna fight Floyd
Mayweather and then you're gonna jump
over the WWE and not only does he jump
over
I don't know WWE what I hear from people
that do follow like dude he's [__]
talented
what yeah and you see him like Logan
Paul jumping off these crazy this day
and age of stay in your lane that's gone
don't limit yourself of course if these
guys can do this and there's other guys
do you come from different backgrounds
and jumping over into this Lane the stay
in your lane that's because everybody
else is terrified to go in other lanes
look what happens when you're not look
what these guys are doing
no matter how you feel about them I
don't like their content I don't like
the way he said this I'm not talking
about that yeah just look what they're
achieving
it's incredible nuts absolutely
incredible and remember we would talk
way before they when Jake was calling
out Conor like like so many years ago
like that's so stupid
there's never it's never and then
suddenly he builds himself up so much
works his ass off and gets to the point
where he beats UFC Champions right or a
champion right in boxing knocks out Ben
ashgren who was a champion you know
speed three Champions dude yeah so he's
Anderson Silva Ben askren
yeah it's legit yeah
so it's incredible and now that we're
actually talking like he could actually
potentially fight Connor fight like you
know these big heads it's incredible
what he's done and after seeing this
would you favor Jake or Connor because
six years ago remember
huge counterfeit you guys know this you
know it kind of holds a dear place in my
heart you said dick rider since day one
dick right since day one gave me
opportunities when I was with Showtime
that made my career because he decided
to fight Floyd Mayweather which is
insane one of the biggest you know
combat fights of all time I had the
privilege of being on that you know on
the broadcast loved it so it kind of
holds a dear place in my heart
carnivorous Jake next year
who would you favor to win that fight
right now yes Jake yeah yeah and nuts
yeah and and we're not hating in any
faster nobody knows they hate and all
that stuff I'm just like
we're just looking at the date out loud
for Jake because he's training he's
young okay he's taking it seriously MMA
different but boxing I'm straight boxing
yeah box now let me ask you this let me
ask you this
and this is kudos to to Floyd and and uh
Connor not kudos to Floyd Kudos Connor
who looked more like a boxer
in these extreme you know fights who
look more like a boxer Jake looked more
like a boxer than any of them so let's
take Jake out of it who looked more like
a boxer
from UFC guys coming over to the boxing
world
did Nate look better as far as straight
boxing
did Nate look better than Woodley or Ben
askren you look better in Ben well of
course Ben yeah look better yeah did he
look better did so the real question is
who looked more like a boxer Connor
against Floyd or Nate against Jake
who had a better outage yeah Connor
definitely looked back Connor
who's known for their boxing Nate it
just shows you the difference that's why
that's all I'm trying and this is no
knock on Nate
boxing is completely different and for
those true boxing heads those dinosaurs
those those straight boxing like oh I
hate this stuff no no this is showing
you how hard boxing is the sweet they
call it the sweet signs for a reason
it's showing you how difficult boxing is
because our very best in the UFC come
over and they don't look good that's how
hard boxing is so I think the MMA fans
are getting gaining a more appreciate
they should I don't know they should
gain more of appreciation for actual
high-level boxing holy [__] I seen that
guy knock out dudes in the UFC and how's
he looking this it doesn't look very
good that's how hard boxing is
yeah but he's trained I know but he
trains in multiple martial arts he has
to worry about multiple things when he
fights in UFC he can't just focus on
boxing also boxing distance boxing when
it comes to the small four ounce gloves
and inside a cage is completely
different you're almost talking about
different sport
than it is compared just real boxing men
different animal
so I think as much as those old boxing
cures want to hate on this stuff I
actually think it it's building box up
and people go damn those guys are
[__] good yeah yeah different animal
Spence Crawford man those guys look good
yeah different animal
but kudos to Connor no one looked at a
confinement that guy can't box he went
[__] Floyd [__] him up but you know it
kind of didn't look like you know and
today you know he is fighting Jake Paul
Jake Paul looked better on all of them
because all he's doing is focus on
boxing
but you were never like like no Conor's
out of you know his balance is off or
his foot Works off or he looks awkward
or Manny stumbling on his feet or none
of that
that was even the narrative on that
thing and Floyd's a way better boxer
that's how hard boxing is man it's the
sweet science that's why guys have 50
fights before they turn pro 100 fights
before they turn pro boxing takes years
and years and years and years to even
remotely get okay at it it's very very
tough man it's the sweet science
virtue but also like MMA is also super
complicated so someone from boxing
coming to MMA get tonight
that's the thing James coming like
[__] awful yeah that's you know
there's just there's two different
things yeah very very different so I
want to ask you this I remember here's
the thing it's okay
well I'll still watch but I'm not
expecting Nate to look like [__]
usick you guys are I'm not expecting
Jake to look like tank Davis you guys
are
it's impossible what they're doing
yeah so you know how you heard the pop
for Nate Diaz in the arena it was like
hardcore it was all about Nate Diaz and
they were booing Jake Paul but you know
if you look at that's what Jake wants if
you look at the data though right so
Jake Paul has way big of a reach big you
know bigger following and all this stuff
so I'm wondering if
and plus you know the the thing that
kind of sucks for Jake Paul too he even
said that sometimes you know since his
fans are younger a lot of them will be
streaming the fight so they're not
actually buying the pay-per-views so
that's tough on him as well but it was a
filled audience I'm sure the paper
provides will be decent right but I mean
like even though Jake Paul has that
reach
so all the people that are buying
tickets at the arena were for Nate or do
you think they are fans of both but they
just prefer Nate or something like that
they're fans of Nate I'm sorry they're
fans of Jake yeah but they want to see
Jake Luke they Jake's the heel and he's
built his Empire based off the heel so
for example uh MC Hammer is my manager
for a long time you know you guys know
this before I get a lot of hate
MC Hammer goes you know because MC
Hammer got a lot of hate he goes when I
would sell merch I used to make shirts
that say empty Hammer sucks I sold 10
more times those than I did of my
regular merch these are my fan LeBron
takes the show but I when I would sell a
shirt that sits up negative about me my
fans would buy that shirt over the other
shirt
so for Jake they're tuning in they're
buying his merch they're doing all this
stuff puts that this heel it's this heel
thing it's this negative thing
it's just the nature of the Beast yeah
because every so you're fans of both but
I mean
yeah people are weird but I mean I'm
also fans of Fighters that I like I like
this fighter better than this fighter
I'm fans of both Fighters you know yeah
so I guess yeah it could be the case
it's a weird world yeah but I mean it
was like overwhelming Nate Diaz yeah
it's like crazy yeah
yeah but then also Jake's fan younger
right so they might not be going to Live
Events 10 year olds yeah like 10 12 year
olds the parents like what I'm not going
to [__] boxing match so maybe they're
not coming Nate's a massive celebrity
and makes martial arts World his fans
are older older definitely older his
demos probably [__] because you you got
to remember it's not because Nate Diaz
fan base Nate Diaz won The Ultimate
Fighter how many years ago he told him
15 years ago at least but probably fifth
before I fought in Ultimate so he
probably won Ultimate Fighter 15 they
probably filmed it 15 years ago
Ultimate Fighter five
just type in Ultimate yeah
what year was that
2007 dude
16 years ago yeah
16 years ago so you know his fan base is
gonna be that fan base where they have
money they go to the Live Events
you know that you're talking about much
older fan base we're gonna attend Live
Events Jake's fanbase super young
I want that legalization about her
daughter she's like do you know Jake
Paul I'm like what yeah and she was
seven eight there ain't no seven
eight-year-old who are a fan of Nate
deals behind his merch he's just it's
just an older so they're more willing to
pay for those events go to the events
the guys get together you're talking
about dads it's just different demo yeah
a lot of yeah and Jake's problem is
because Demo's so young these kids
aren't they're not showing the respect
and paying for the fights they're
legally streaming it because they can so
we're so good at it it's impossible to
catch them with the uh Express VPN so
it's impossible to catch them so
they might say you know Jake Paul's
fight does whatever 200 000 paper he
buys but when you talk about legal
streams talk about people watching here
well over I mean he's talking about two
three five six million people
never know he's all right though
what else you got
um so you did kind of mention this on
Joe Rogan's podcast but you didn't
really dive into it so Jake Paul said
he's making a seven figure offer to your
boy Bradley Martin versus Mike Perry and
Mike Perry answered saying like I hit
like a 260 pounder anyways I'm down to
fight
yeah so it started right Bradley wants
to fight uh Mighty Mouse well you just
always ask everyone yeah he asked
everybody he wants to grab on my mouse
which is going to happen in September
and then you know obviously Jake Paul
offers him a fight against Mike Perry so
is he talking about
a straight boxing match because because
I'll do Bradley if me and Bradley
Bradley's not trying to box Bradley's
not a box he knows his limitations he's
not a boxer he would never fight Mike
Perry in a boxing or bare knuckle match
that's not his thing now
if Perry wants to Grapple I bet Bradley
would entertain that and I was talking
about uh
this with Brian Cowan I'm finding the
kid just re filmed in Austin yesterday
at the drinking Bros uh set I said which
is do you think is more favorable to
Bradley Martin grappling with Mighty
Mouse who's pound for pound goat would
you quick as [__] legit black belt many
times over you know ridiculous
submissions in the UFC and you know one
championship
is he gonna have more success because my
mouse is smaller but way more skilled
than Mike Perry is in grappling even
though Mike Perry probably maybe walks
at 190 but he's maybe a purple belt does
it not not known for submissions not
known for his wrestling would you if
you're a Bradley Martin fan do you think
he has a better opportunity against
Mighty Mouse
because he's 130 pounds on maybe 140
walking around or does he have better
opportunity to have success again it's a
guy like Mike Perry who's slower than
Mighty Mouse he's not a high level black
belt he's not a high level Grappler he
doesn't have a wrestling background
I told Brian I said I'd take my shots if
I'm Bradley it's just grappling I'm
taking my shot with Mike Perry
as far as grappling goes
might have asked me hard to get under
you're not gonna get a single leg now
you can be able to pick him up and do
that whatever the good luck Mike Perry
you should have more realistic a bigger
body you know easier to get to his legs
the strength there with you know not as
skilled as a Mighty Mouse I think he has
a better opportunity to out grapple Mike
Perry I don't think y'all grapples in
him would be very clear but if you're on
team Bradley Martin you'd rather see him
go against Mike Perry than Mighty Mouse
now the intrigues is Mighty Mouse is
Tiny his name is Mighty Mouse
But Mighty Mouse is so skilled
so the stuff I'm seeing here is is in a
street fight which obviously that's not
gonna happen
so that's the challenge yeah Jake Paul's
saying Bradley Martin versus Mike Perry
in a street fight Mike Perry's down but
that's can't that can't be safe you
can't be sanctioned can't be any of that
yeah so talk about that does that you
want to back it up it's time for
everybody to either man up or shut up
and Bradley I have seven figures for you
seven figures cast to fight Mike Perry
and quote unquote street fight which is
what you're talking about stop boxing
not MMA it could be a street fight Mike
pair is already down say he's gonna do
it you're bigger than so this goes along
with your whole size Advantage Theory
and you now have the opportunity to make
seven figures to fight Mike Perry a
massive name prove to the world maybe
prove me wrong maybe prove everyone else
wrong about your theory of thinking that
you can beat these smaller guys in a
street fight that's the deal take it or
leave it man up or shut up now Bradley
originally won his original plan is he
wants to fight Logan Paul and he'll
fight Logan Paul in an MMA fight wow
I think that's more realistic than you
know Mike Perry that you're really
talking about here you know like this I
Bradley's never gonna take a fight I
spoke to Bradley about this Bradley goes
no no hate on Mike Perry at all I've
never heard of him
he just you know he never heard of
Mighty Mouse so he I was like uh Perry's
a Savage dude as far as bare knuckle
goes like the guy who's a born pit bull
like you don't want to fight that guy
so apparently Logan called him out yeah
Logan called him out so he's just doing
for clicks and then Brad was like dude
come to my gym No cameras nothing let's
fight in the street now that's stupid if
we're gonna do this let's make some
money
so is Logan down to fight Bradley
because that's more fun but Bradley
Fighting Mighty Mouse Bradley fight you
know Mighty Mouse you're talking about a
legend Bradley fight Mike Perry that's
not happening in a sentient fight
Bradley versus Logan Paul
sign me up that sounds way more fair
yeah that's more fair
no one's really gonna get hurt you know
it's like they both
you know what I'm saying though like my
parents can I buy a pro my parent
changer DNA yeah like Mike Perry versus
Bradley Martin you're allowed punches
he's gonna you shouldn't change your
health I don't want that for badly
Mighty Mouse grappling match she's not
gonna nosy and hurt
Logan Paul Bradley in a boxer and I
think he'd he would MMA fight Logan
because he's thinking his grappling's
gonna be the difference
take my money I'll watch that that's
where this should lead it should be we
should Point our energy toward Logan
versus Bradley not Bradley getting
murdered by a [__] bare knuckle world
champion
she waited the Luke rockhold who skilled
as [__] how dare you
what else you got all right since we
talked about Logan Paul a little bit
here he was in a scuffle
and no one knows exactly why this
happened but I'll just show you the
video real quick here
all right
someone pulled the chair out
people fall down that's being Nate Diaz
fans
yeah
it's funny he seems still still in his
WrestleMania or WWE outfit like he just
literally didn't change and just flew
over yeah he came by he looks like he's
one of the characters from kick ass
he does yeah yeah
um where was that what I was gonna say
so anyway you talked about on Rogan's
podcast but there's that guy Derek from
better from Jake Paul's team that the
dorky skinny guy yeah and he called out
Nate Diaz again uh in a bad way like in
the press conference he's like I hope
you know Jake Paul knocks you the [__]
out this and that and then Nate went on
this tirade but I thought Jake fired him
no he still this is all trolling it
might but Nate it seemed like Nate was
legitimately yeah really pissed off so
he said the f word you know yeah you
know that f word he said N word every he
said a bunch of stuff he was like dude
these guys disrespecting us like this
and blah blah whatever yeah
that even happened like that stuff's not
cool I imagine that and I I think for
Jake
like because you know a lot of the MMA
fan base and casuals view this as like a
gimmick doing that stuff pushes that
narrative more don't allow that we don't
you you doing what you're doing is we
that's enough this guy we don't need
dude I hate this guy I don't care if
it's a troll job or not I hate him I
don't like this guy at all I think
everybody does bud okay yeah well
I'm sure people gonna see him on the
street I don't want him to get destroyed
but
so this is a real quick one Conor
McGregor during the whole time that he's
like watching the Jake Paul fight
because he's saying like or the sorry
the Nate Diaz versus Jake Paul he said
Nate Diaz we'll still do the trilogy no
matter what happens but as he's watching
the fight he's like [__] this what's up
sweetie yeah she looked amazing
yeah she looked incredibly hot yeah a
little bit of this so she takes off her
Swahili or sweetie
sweetie
but yeah God
does
what if Connor's wife's ever like hey
man but she knows what she signed up for
I assume yeah
she's super rich
uh yeah and I do so I'll say this too
the last thing on Jake Paul
you know Jake Paul offered Nadia's uh
MMA fight
where this gets tricky again and Nate
would be a huge favor in that and he
should be
if that were to happen to pfl and Nate
dote goes to pfl direction for the money
that 10 million or whatever they're
offering them
if he does do that you're never getting
the trilogy fight with Conor Dana's not
gonna allow it
if he what if he wins
because he hit him fighting for another
organization Dana's never let him come
back
know I know about Dana that if he does
decide to do that then you're forfeiting
the Conor McGregor fight in the UFC
I don't think
then Jake has a deal with pfl I don't
think it's gonna allow him to fight in
the UFC
so I I think if Nate they gotta figure
it out what's best because it you know
he would much easier fight against Jake
and MMA right 10 million well how much
would you make fighting Conor McGregor
in the UFC legit fight big fight Main
Event the media behind it the PowerHouse
machine of the UFC like what do you want
to do here
seems like he would make
pretty good money either way but
probably way more in UFC yeah
I wouldn't do it
so Ariel apparently did an interview
with Yuri prashka and then according to
Jamal Hill when he when he saw the
interview he was saying like you're kind
of pushing to say some bad stuff about
me right and if you watch the interview
it looks a little you know I don't know
a little odd but I don't know so anyways
journalist skin or journalist yeah so so
after that happened
um Jamal did this whole video about
Ariel being like this hater this
involved what do you do it at in his own
podcast oh yeah okay and then so then
Ariel found out about it and arrows with
the at the weigh-ins for the the Paul
Diaz fight and he you know said okay I
heard what you said why don't you come
on my podcast and we'll talk about it
right and he said like yeah I have all
this the receipts of what you said this
narrow has the receipt yeah okay so then
um just you know come on the podcast and
we can you know hash it out
and then that's fine but then Jamal's
like no I'm not gonna go on your podcast
you call my podcast Type move and then I
have other receipts you said it ended on
a good note but then his last messages
were like not on a good note and he
pushed he posted on his uh Jamal did
yeah on his on his podcast I don't know
who's right wrong but real housewives of
mixed martial laws
and I think the last thing I saw was
like Arrow saying like yeah it's it's
whatever I'm not gonna go on your
podcast this is what I kind of remember
seeing but I remember exactly
uh I'd have to see the interview I you
know they said by Zoom either do you
have to be physically at the podcast you
can be by Zoom as well I bet Ariel do it
I think he's he was like huh oh he
doesn't want to do it
here we go
like he's sleeping Jamal with another
response to the to the response to the
response she's so much drama good kind
of for budding Channel though well
played saw this latest one more lies
more made up stuff his manager knows but
all good I'm bored off on the table if
you change your mind
I bet they make up
and then uh Hawaii's then shared a
screenshot of the conversation between
Jamal Hills manager Brian Butler which
prompted Hill to retaliate with a
barrage of tweets like I said you
reached out for your boy and why didn't
you add the phone call in between these
text messages where he brought up not
just me but Buckley as well you're so
desperate you expose yourself I'm always
real just man up and own your [__] you
had real ones that follow the sport know
what this is about when it started how
long I've kept quiet and why the year
interview was the last straw
yeah I said so people should just watch
that your interview and just you know
take what you I don't know enough about
it to really comment on it I mean you
know drama there's always drama in this
world yeah
huh but one of them should just go on
the show and squash the beef I don't I
don't get it yeah I think since like I
told hero when me and him were beefing
on like you know
I think I was planning to go to New York
Times I was like come on the show he's
like really I don't care I'd go on this
show I've
I don't hate the guy I think he's one of
the best if not the best journalists we
have
yeah I mean I think it's fun for the
fans to talk about it's more drama for
the fans I never take it that serious
alrighty
um I bet Jamal Hill and Ariel's not even
thinking about it the fans are it's a
it's a real housewives of Combat Sports
what's that Mike Tyson saying oh
so I think
oh man he goes
he trusts and I guess they did get
together at some point and he says like
you know yeah Francis said he Mike's
part of his cam well he definitely asked
him in the beginning he wanted to train
with him I guess they did kind of meet
up and do a little bit of training
and go up to the quote with Mike saying
tougher fight than anyone thinks yeah
listen and I said this uh to Rogan you
know I said
Fury has a better shot at winning this
fight against Tyson Fury I'm sorry
Francis has a better shot of beating
Tyson Fury in a boxing match than Conor
does beaten Floyd
because they're heavyweights because the
the One-Shot knockout power if he just
goes wild in that anything lands Fury is
in trouble
and I I do think if um
in
francis's Heir I'm going we're going for
broke one round two rounds Max where
this thing could be a 10 round 12 round
fight where you're an outclass this guy
it's just not in the cards
you're doing like the rosenstruke fight
you're fighting like you know Lisa
Simpson when she's fighting Bart and
spending the you really fought roads and
streaking was just like [__] it
technique out the window if one of these
lands this thing's over that's what you
got to do you're not gonna outclass
Tyson Fury it's gonna be very tough to
hit where we're trained for two rounds
of [__] Fury in Saudi Arabia two
rounds
and remember we watched six minutes of
pure Francis ingano power and we watch
that slow motion picture gonna lose
if you if if you don't get done the
first two we're gonna lose we're willing
to take that let's go it's two rounds of
[__] Fury good luck to anybody can
withstand that power for two rounds
if anybody can it's Tyson fear his
footwork's insane his defense insane I
get all that
I'm saying if one of them [__]
African bombs land we're going Sizzler
and then there's a rematch
did you knocking out class Tyson Fury in
10 Rounds or 12 rounds whatever they're
doing it's not happening it's not in the
cards but what we do have is this atomic
bomb from [__] Nigeria
so that's his best bet just like
swarm dude technique out the window just
throwing bombs I agree
you always mention this right is this
the one that you saw because I can't
nope that one's terrible I've seen the
actual I kept Googling it I couldn't
find the actual thing
that one's awful all right no so this is
your impossible two faces Alex I can't
believe you can't find it I'll find it
for you it's all over send it to me I
Googled that poster it's just on
Instagram
anywho
oh so he he said on an interview with uh
I think block asset
but he would like to train with Jon
Jones and Jon Jones agreed so that they
would train together that'd be cool John
has gor I was trying to get uh Gordon
around on fire as a kid and then Gordon
was like ah sorry man Albuquerque
Albuquerque train Jon Jones like Jesus
Christ they're like shooting guns and
stuff too yeah and [__] choking
people unconscious that's sick
uh I'll say that for there so this one I
I didn't know this but so there's a one
Championship over the weekend yeah I'll
post about it thanks for following
thank you
I'm not on social media that often but
anyways so uh tyrotolo I saw this and
this bothered me so much his opponent
basically tapped out once and then said
what I didn't tap out so tyrocello came
back I'll just show you and then just
see his reaction after this brothers are
those twins are they're saying yeah
our boy Mikey mushrooms so he slaps him
in the ass he tapped up there
but he's like nah
he's like oh really
[Music]
why didn't the ref stop it
but look at the guy
he's like what okay he's like what the
hell baby not only did you get tapped
out once but twice
that bothers me so much
but uh yeah anyway your boy Mikey
musumechi also won yeah dog John lineker
one yep our boy
um uh bushesha did not look great
striking has some work to do but you
know he's new
alrighty
Mikey mushumeshi with a triangle arm bar
he looked he's so
he's such a beast
and I think oh so Drake did a six-figure
bet he lost obviously he bet on Nate
um this was kind of cool this is a
fighter UFC Cody Durden he had a life
rips mouthpiece and Chris Leo posted
about it
for the fights did Chris pay this guy
there's no way Chris doesn't know what
UFC in anything I doubt it little does
he know this fighter that's dope though
yeah that's pretty cool
bless you
and these are the fights you're the
fight night and knock your hair back so
my favorites are fine no Vicente lique
versus uh dos Angels phenomenal Main
Event then you got our boy Cleo
Roundtree I should wear shoes today I'll
wear them this week he sent me some dope
thick boy shoes Cleo Roundtree or it's
Chris uh dacus
uh Vienna's fight never mad at that
Juliana Miller fan favorite
it says Cub swans is that still going
down it's Wikipedia you've seen what UFC
man
oh it's going down all right Cubs
fighting dollar dude
that's a good fight too
that's on Saturday yep Apex so that's 4
P.M Pacific
uh I'll be at the UFL with you yep but
Friday two shows only almost sold out
stand up live in Phoenix Arizona can be
hot during the day either Friday or
Saturday and catch me at JT Wings eating
all the wings but Phoenix one night only
August 11th that's this freaking Friday
then Omaha Nebraska August 16th one
night two shows only Kansas City
Missouri one night only two shows August
17th and then Covina California Covina
Laugh Factory Brian Cowan and myself
find the kids September 8th and 9th then
Spokane Washington September 21st
through the 23rd that's one of my
favorite Spokane in Washington then
skank Fest or close September skank Fest
Las Vegas September 29th through October
1st Niagara Falls November 4th through
the 5th we'll have a bunch more dates
coming up being announced but uh Phoenix
I will see you this Friday stand up live
all right and then I'm off to Omaha and
Kansas City all right kids that's it be
nice to each other see you next time
thanks for tuning in like subscribe to
all the things these these YouTubers
tell you to do love you see ya